je vais commencer et terminer en parlant
de désintérêt mais à les voir en quoi on
parle en d1 terme je parle de l'hôpital
les internes et lisse ni ses dix mille
adhérents sur 30000 interne en france
les internes c'est 40 % du personnel
médical des hôpitaux
c'est des chiffres de la drees
c'est également on en a beaucoup parlé
un dépassement du temps de travail
chronique et généraliser ces 57 eur en
moyenne plus de 80 heures dans les
disciplines chirurgicale et c'est un
constat qui a été confirmée encore très
récemment par l' enquête du ministère de
la santé
donc pour résumer les internes c'est
l'hôpital d'aujourd'hui
de demain et c'est une sorte de
thermomètre et je peux vous dire que le
thermomètre est cassé car il ya une
étude à paraître qui est terrible
pourquoi terrible parce qu'elle dit que
23 % seulement des internes considère
que l'activité à l'hôpital public est
attractive
alors je vais insister sur trois points
qui reviennent souvent mais qui sont
essentielles qui ont été abordés
peut-être par le ségur de la santé mais
seulement abordé c'est d'une part la
question managériale ce que j'appelle
l'hydre managériale hospitalière qu'est
ce que c'est bien le péché originel je
pense et c'est ce qu'on rapporte souvent
aligné depuis des années c'est l'absence
de séparation du gradé de la fonction et
ça ça et ça a un coût extrême
d'une part vous avez ce qu'on appelait à
l'époque les mandarins des professeurs
d'université praticiens hospitaliers une
aristocratie médical et cette
aristocratie médicale elle cumule quatre
fonctions l'enseignement la recherche la
clinique et le management c'est
doublement problématique la première
réponse c'est qu'une journée en fait de
24 heures très difficile de cumuler ces
quatre fonctions de manière
satisfaisante
la seconde aussi tout à fait évidente
c'est que ce sont des personnes qui
malgré leur bonne volonté
non pour l'immense majorité strictement
aucune formation la dernier la réponse
extrêmement importante c'est que lorsque
les postes lorsque la possibilité de
s'investir et trusté par encore en
particulier et que vous ne trouvez pas
votre place qu'est ce que vous faites
vous partez
le deuxième corps la deuxième tête de
cette hydre c'est les directeurs
d'hôpitaux voyez tout le monde en prend
pour son grade ge a aucune forme de
corporatisme dans mes propos ces
directeurs d'hôpitaux et bien ils
subissent les mêmes écueils qu'a pu
subir l'ena qui a été très largement
réformée puisqu'elle a même changé de
nom vous avez des personnes qui ont qui
ont toute l'efficacité et la bonne
volonté du monde mais en tout cas qui
ont une forme de pensée unique une école
unique et un système d'avancement et de
promotion unique par le centre national
de gestion qui est piloté par des
directeurs d'hôpitaux et cette hydre
elle a aussi un dernier problème c'est
qu'elle y ait une imperméabilité totale
entre ses différentes têtes c'est à dire
que l'aristocratie médicale les
professeurs les chefs de service et les
la direction hospitalière se parle très
peu souvent se détestent souvent pour
des guerres d'ego tout à fait et vous
voulez vous les avez suffisamment
entendue pour savoir à quel point ça
devient presque enfantin mais c'est
extrêmement important et cette
imperméabilité cette non compréhension
elle coûte beaucoup et les médecins
comme les administrateurs en sont
responsables il faut pas se dédouaner
deuxième point et je tiendrai le temps
du président le financement
excessivement important savais que ça
fait des années que le financement des
hôpitaux se fait sur l'activité je crois
qu'il ya un problème majeur c'est qu'on
a on s'est peut-être trompé sur ce que
devait être l'activité l'activité ça
devient une gesticulation médical et une
gesticulation de santé au lieu d'être ce
qui à mon avis à notre avis devrait être
et c'est quoi et bien c'est de se dire
que l'activité ça doit être d'une part
le service rendu et la pertinence des
soins ça n'est donc pas la question
économique la pertinence des soins c'est
le bon soin c'est le juste soin au bon
moment et ça c'est excessivement
important et sur le plan économique et
sur le service rendu au patient et le
dernier point peut-être le plus rapide
c'est celui de l' isolement en un
problème majeur en france c'est qu'on a
imaginé le système de santé comme un
agglomérat d'établissement et
professionnelle alors même que la seule
façon utile de le penser c'est de mettre
le patient au centre très démago dire ça
mais quand vous pensez aux parcours
d'impatience et fois impatient il va
voir un médecin libéral en ville puis il
va éventuellement dans un hôpital puis
éventuellement dans une clinique et là
le meilleur moyen de communiquer on le
sait bien c'est de parler plus ou moins
la même langue lorsque vous avez des
systèmes d'information qui sont
différents l'impossibilité de transférer
immédiatement des dossiers d'un patient
qu'est ce qui arrive est bien quelque
chose de très simple ce que j'ai vécu
tant de fois vous voyez un patient rimer
sur le bras car avec une pile de
dossiers comme ça vous savez qu'il a
fait des imageries on vous dit vous
inquiétez pas vous les transfèrera et
vous mettez parfois 48 heures pour les
recevoir donc parfois vous refaites des
examens que vous aviez déjà fait ça
c'est excessivement important et c'est
une des visas devrait être une des
priorités d'action et donc j'en termine
en reparlant des internes vous ai dit
que c'était un thermomètre et ce
thermomètre il est si grippe et qui sont
aujourd'hui séquestrée dans les chu
j'utilise ce mot parce que il ya pouvez
interroger à peu près tout le monde vous
verrez qu'on veut absolument qu'ils y
restent c'est à dire qu'ils n'aillent
pas se former dans le privé mais qu'il
n'aille pas aussi se former dans les
hôpitaux périphérie donc les hôpitaux
périphériques eux mêmes reproches cette
situation là est la conséquence est
l'épuisement le burn out et je
terminerai avec ce chiffre de la sent
qu'il ya quelques mois de cela nous
avons organisé un colloque à l'assemblée
nationale sur la santé mentale des
jeunes médecins des internes le résultat
je vous laisse avec lui c'est 25% de
dépression maladie l'année précédente
chez ces internes et étudiants en
médecine je vous remercie les bains
c'est nous qui vous remercions pour
caractère très direct et très voilé de
vos propos et très structurée merci
docteur chamard autres ain
monsieur le président madame la
rapporteure mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs tout d'abord je vous remercie
d'avoir invité jeunes médecins pour
témoigner devant votre commission je
remercie également mes collègues qui ont
dû se réorganiser pour que je puisse
venir devant vous aujourd'hui donc je
suis médecin anesthésiste réanimatrice
ans et j'exerce en tant que ph en
réanimation chirurgicale aux hôpitaux
universitaires de strasbourg je fais
partie des médecins aussi à l'origine de
la minute de silence or qui a lieu
actuellement tous les vendredi à 14
heures sur le parvis des hôpitaux et
donc mouvement prend de l'ampleur
et je témoigne devant vous en tant que
vice-président de jeunes médecins en
charge de la médecine hospitalière
donc jeune médecin est un syndicat
professionnel représentant près de 5000
adhérents de toutes spécialités et de
trois mois d'exercice confondues son but
est donc de représenter les intérêts des
jeunes médecins sans parti pris pour une
spécialité ou pour un mode d'exercice
comme beaucoup de soignants les jeunes
médecins m l'un des taux d'intérêt
général au centre de leur exercice et
s'attache à défendre leur mission de
soins auprès du public l'intérêt de
votre commission est majeur l' oms a
récemment alerté sur le risque
d'effondrement de notre système de santé
à cause notamment de la pandémie de kobe
de 19 cet effondrement qui aura lieu du
fait de la souffrance notamment des
soignants cette souffrance elle atteint
son paroxysme alors que les moyens
disposition pour soutenir les soignants
sont pauvres tellement pauvre que les
experts de l'observatoire national de la
qualité de vie au travail on réellement
récemment démissionné or cette
souffrance à la un retentissement sur le
système ensemble de santé car il aboutit
en fait à la faire elles abouti à la
fermeture de lits faute de soignants
épuisé l'enfant en arrêt maladie ou qui
quittent leurs fonctions des goûters
notamment à ségur qui n'a pas été à la
heures et qui a même était cynique en
effet concernant les ph la
revalorisation de la grille salariale
n'a concerné que les péages qui sont
nommés depuis fin novembre 2020 en fin
de mi temps même pire des mesures ont
été prises pour déclasser les péages
plus anciens qui étaient sur le front du
co lead par exemple pour moi qui ai été
déclassé deschamps 4 à 1 en janvier 2021
et j'ai vu d'anciens interne ce que j'ai
encadré dans pour leur mémoire de thèse
ou de death être nommé échelon 2 je suis
vraiment heureuse pour eux et je
comprends pas cette inéquité d'ailleurs
jeune médecin a déposé un recours auprès
du conseil d'état et plus de 8000 th ont
fait un recours devant le tribunal
administratif pour contente pour
contester ce reclassement
le cdur qui concerne également les
paramédicaux n'a pas été suffisant de
leur côté également ça n'a pas permis de
juguler l'hémorragie de ses soignants
dans chu par exemple on explique on
estime à 200 ou 260 qui fermé par manque
de personnel paramédical leyrit les
chiffres restent toutefois opaque tout
ça ça se passe dans un système de santé
qui est vraiment hospital au centre et
en termes de formation et de prise en
charge
en effet il faudrait profiter en fait de
ce contexte d'ouverture avec le numerus
à perthus je pense pour que nous
formions plus de médecins généralistes
notamment quitte à ce que ceux ci se
spécialise dans une autre spécialité
ambulatoire en plus comme par exemple la
pédiatrie la gynécologie médicale ou
encore les urgences ça permettrait il
faudrait également permettre aux
internes de médecine générale d'accéder
à plus de stages ambulatoire
et les former à la gestion notamment des
cabinets cette formation logistique elle
est trop parcellaires au cours de leur
internat cela permettra le cela aiderait
également la création en fait des
maisons de garde pluri professionnelle
de premier recours en fait qui
permettrait de désengorger les urgences
hospitalières qui sont actuellement un
des seuls remparts face à une
désertification médicale galopante
concernant l'accord l'interconnexion
ville hôpital elle est insuffisamment
exploité comme le disait mon collègue du
fait notamment de logiciels médicaux qui
sont plus plurielle les professionnels
sont actuellement suffisamment formés au
logiciel unique tel que l'espace
numérique de santé qui a succédé en
début d'année au dmp
et la convergence de ces logiciels on le
sait ça permettrait de faciliter les
échanges entre les professionnels et
améliorer la prise en charge des
patients notamment sur tout d'ailleurs
concernant aussi l'exercice mix il ya un
lien nouveau statut unique de praticiens
hospitaliers qui doit voir le jour
prochainement or déjà il ne répond pas
aux besoins actuels de lien à resserrer
entre ville et hôpital du fait d'une
clause de non concurrence qui empêchera
les ph d'exercer en libéral dans un
rayon de 10 km donc c'est en
contradiction avec l'objectif initial de
ce nouveau statut qui était de favoriser
un exercice mixte
concernant les mesures qui ont été
prises pour l'attractivité hospitalo
universitaires elles sont insuffisantes
il serait vraiment nécessaire de
revaloriser
les salaires de ceux qui s'engagent dans
la voie hospitalo universitaire tout le
long de leur carrière d'intégrer leur
temps de travail hospitalier dans le
calcul de la retraite ce qui n'est pas
encore fait
il faudrait plus de transparence
également et de visibilité au niveau des
postes
et c'est vraiment nécessaire pour ceux
qui veulent s'engager pleinement dans
cette carrière parce qu'il ya beaucoup
trop de déçu à la fin
et du fait des changements sociétaux il
faut vraiment une attention particulière
pour l'équilibré vie personnelle et vie
professionnelle dans cette voie
notamment
donc voilà un panorama des difficultés
actuelles et quelques solutions qui sont
proposées par jeunes médecins et nous
nous vous avons également remis en début
de séance notre livret blanc avec
justement des propositions et notamment
dans d'autres champs d'action voilà
merci beaucoup et bien merci beaucoup
également manara ringer
bonjour à tous monsieur le président
madame la rapporteure mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices
je représente donc l'isnar img qui est
la structure représentative des internes
de médecine générale est à l'heure
actuelle on sait que de très nombreux
internes sont en extrême souffrance du
fait de la situation de l'hôpital
j'aimerais donc profiter de cette
intervention pour vous apporter quelques
éléments de contexte et faire le lien
avec la situation en médecine de ville
la pandémie actuelle n'a fait que mettre
en lumière un mal être déjà présents
depuis de nombreuses années
nos organisations font constat
régulièrement à travers les enquêtes
santé mentale dont les résultats sont
toujours plus catastrophique celle de
2021 a montré qu'un étudiant sur quatre
ce chiffre de 25% un étudiant sur quatre
a présenté un épisode dépressif
caractérisée sur les douze derniers mois
ce qui est à la base une vocation
devient de plus en plus un fardeau
depuis plusieurs années nous assistons à
une lente agonie de l'hôpital public une
réforme d'envergure doit être réalisée
les zones jeu les jeunes médecins sont
porteurs de solutions et d'initiatives
pour améliorer cette situation
l'attractivité de l'hôpital public doit
être une des priorités des
établissements les jeunes aspirent à une
meilleure qualité vie leur permettant de
concilier vie professionnelle et vie
personnelle
actuellement 70% des internes déclarent
travailler au delà des 48 heures
hebdomadaires qui sont légales et cela
en toute impunité
une remise en question globale des
conditions de travail des internes doit
voir le jour avec une généralisation des
tableaux de service nous permettant de
suivre notre temps de travail mais cela
doit aller plus loin nous réclamant des
sanctions à destination des
établissements de le respectant pas la
prise en compte du temps de travail de
la qualité de vie dans la délivrance des
agréments de stage la possibilité de
retirer ou suspendre les agréments en
quelle violence de manière générale il
faut revoir la culture du monde
hospitalier qui normalise voire
encouragent les violences les
humiliations les agressions les chiffres
sont effarants un étudiant en médecine
sur quatre déclarent avoir subi une
forme de harcèlement
la même proportion rapporte des
humiliations et on dénombre jusqu'à 3%
d'agression sexuelle
les annonces gouvernementales nous
laisse espérer des améliorations en ce
sens cependant la maltraitance quasi
institutionnalisée de nos services
hospitaliers demande un investissement
constant et des changements systémiques
il est temps de remettre la
bienveillance et la solidarité au coeur
de notre système de soins
cette problématique du temps de travail
touche durement les internes qui sont
pressurisées pour maintenir à flot des
hôpitaux presque submergé le manque de
moyens matériels le manque de moyens
humains la vétusté de certains locaux
l'épuisement des personnels tout ceci
aboutit à une perte de sens de nos
métiers qui ne présente plus d'attrait
pour les général les jeunes générations
plein d'espoir
j'ai bien conscience que ces
problématiques aggrave les difficultés
déjà présentes de recrutement et de
fidélisation du personnel médical
j'aimerais insister sur l'impact négatif
que ce problème assure les internes
particulièrement ceux de médecine
générale qui réalisent des stages dans
les petits centres hospitaliers encore
plus durement touchées par la pénurie de
médecins en effet comment obtenir une
formation de qualité quand les médecins
seniors supposé nous épauler nous
enseigner sont eux mêmes bien trop
débordés ou bien change tous les mois
une réorganisation du système doit voir
le jour permettant de libérer du temps
médical en diminuant les charges
administratives et en augmentant le
temps passé auprès des mâles mais le
manque de temps et de moyens ne sont
malheureusement pas l'apanage de notre
hôpital le milieu ambulatoire est
également en souffrance les médecins
généralistes pierre angulaire du système
sont en tension et ne sont même pas à
même de répondre à la demande de soins
le nombre de médecins généralistes a
diminué au profit d'une augmentation du
nombre total d autres spécialités
le constat est là nous ne sommes pas
assez nombreux
en parallèle l'augmentation et le
vieillissement de la population on crée
un besoin de soins plus important avec
une augmentation des pathologies
chroniques des problématiques de
maintien à domicile et des prises en
charge toujours plus complexe et
chronophage les problématiques liées au
vieillissement sont plus prégnante que
jamais et nécessite de revoir
l'organisation du système de soins afin
de permettre une prise en charge
coordonnée entre les différents
professionnels avec des moyens de
communication adaptés pour autant les
jeunes ont toujours eu envie de soigner
et d'aider la population
80% des internes de médecine générale
envisage un exercice en milieu rural ou
semi rural alors qu'est ce qui pourrait
aider ces jeunes médecins qui souhaitent
s'installer la création d'un guichet
unique facilitateur d'installation pour
les jeunes générations
permettrait de simplifier les démarches
et supprimerait un frein important les
aides financières seuls ne peuvent
suffire à résoudre ces problématiques
elles doivent permettre d'initier un
accompagnement du jeune médecin dans son
installation
la présence de service public de
transport d'un emploi pour le ou la
conjointe sont tout autant de levier
permettant de rendre les territoires
attractifs
pour les internes est selon l' enquête
sur les déterminants à l'installation du
conseil national de l'ordre des médecins
le premier facteur déterminant
l'installation et la proximité familiale
et le deuxième la présence de service
public
l'aspect financier bien que n'étant pas
majoritaire reste un des moyens d'action
possible en ce sens le nouveau contrat
de début d'exercice qui a été lancé en
février dernier permet non seulement une
aide financière mais également une
couverture sociale majoré il doit être
développées et proposées le plus
largement possible aux jeunes
générations
autres deviez d'action pour favoriser
l'installation et encourager les jeunes
à s'installer dans les territoires sont
du développement des stages en milieu
ambulatoire pour permettre la découverte
des territoires les étudiants de foire
et accueilli être accueillis dans des
bonnes conditions notamment en ville
développement des hébergements
territoriaux d'étudiants en santé les
lobbies les augmentations des indemnités
de transport qui est actuellement à 130
euros par mois et étaient figés depuis
2014 ce sont des leviers qui permettent
les implantations des internes la
formation doit cependant risque reste et
qualitative et ne pas être dégoûté
préalablement des étudiants déjà éprouvé
par un système maltraitant actuellement
encore trop centré sur le chu la
formation doit s'ouvrir à la multitude
des exercices possible en médecine et si
je devais choisir un mot sur ce qui
manque aujourd'hui à notre système de
santé je pense que c'est la
bienveillance remettre la bienveillance
au coeur de notre système de soins c'est
de permettre à chaque étudiant de
découvrir les multiples facettes de la
médecine et s'épanouir dans cette
merveilleuse profession qu'ils ont
choisi
c'est permettre à chacun d'exercer
librement sans contrainte à
l'installation il remettre la confiance
aux mains des professionnels garants
d'un système de santé pour laquelle il
s'échine déjà la bienveillance et gacé
garantir à tous les soignants un
épanouissement professionnel permettant
un équilibre entre vie privée et vie
professionnelle propice à la pérennité
de notre système de soins et enfin c'est
redonner à tous les soignants à tous les
soignants les moyens d'apporter des
soins dignes et de qualité à
l'intégralité de la population la
bienveillance pour les soignants
aujourd'hui c'est permettent de
construire un système de soins qui sera
bénéfique à chacun de nos passions plus
tard je vous remercie eh bien merci
beaucoup également d'auteur le chevalier
dr chevallier vous m'entendez
je suis là vous m'entendez oui on vous
entend vous écoute
allez-y vous la parole
merci merci monsieur le président madame
le rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs donc je
représente le regroupement autonome des
généralistes veulent installer les
remplaçants donc les médecins
généralistes étaient installés depuis
moins de cinq ans remplaçants et les
jeunes universitaires donc la vision que
je vais vous rapporter la vision vu par
les jeunes médecins généralistes qui ont
un exercice
majoritairement ambulatoire mais on ne
peut pas parler d'hôpital sans parler
d'ambulatoire donc comme
l'adie et ma consoeur dr ncaa on voit
une augmentation de la charge de travail
en ambulatoire dit à plusieurs facteurs
dont l'augmentation de la population du
vieillissement de la population avec ces
pathologies chroniques et une diminution
du temps médical également puisque les
médecins généralistes notre génération
n'ont pas vocation non pas l'aspiration
à travailler avoir la même charge ce
travail que leurs aînés et on voit aussi
globalement une surmédicalisation de la
société en france avec un recours à la
consultation pour des motifs
administratifs que ce soit des
certificats les arrêts de travail pour
des pathologies bénignes ou des
pathologies qui pourrait être gérée à la
maison éventuellement avec l'aide des
autres professionnels de santé que ce
soit les pharmaciens
les infirmiers etc et globalement d'une
façon générale assez peu de d'éducation
à la santé en france ce qui fait qu'il
ya une demande de soins qui est
importante et cette demande de soins en
ambulatoire se répercutent
inévitablement pour tout ce qui est du
son le programme et vers les services
d'urgence donc on voit des services
d'urgence qui sont saturés par des
pathologies qui pourraient être vus en
médecine de ville et qui ne peuvent pas
suite à une absence de réponse possible
par par surcharge de travail
globalement les urgences sont également
la porte d'entrée de l'hôpital pour un
médecin généraliste c'est très compliqué
de d'adressé invasion directement dans
le service qui est concernée pour la
pathologie qui l'a très généralement on
demande au médecin d'avoir c'est le
patient aux urgences donc ce qui
entraîne également une charge de travail
pour les urgences qui n'est pas
justifiée puisque le patient de nouveau
à passer par les urgences puis être
réorientés par le service hospitalier
qui le concerne
globalement le regard de la médecine
générale sur
les patients hospitalisés sur les
hospitalisations on voit qu'il ya des
plus en charge de plus en plus rapides
avec des objectifs de durée de séjour
sans forcément d'anticipation de la
suite de la prise en charge en
ambulatoire avec une communication
insuffisante du côté médical donc entre
les médecins et unac sens de
l'anticipation de certaines
problématiques médicales et sociales
donc concrètement c'est des patients qui
y manque d'autonomie qui sont envoyées à
la maison puisque il n'y a pas la
possibilité de les garder en ambulatoire
parce qu'ils en hospitalisation parce
qu'il ya des objectifs de durée de
séjour et qui se retrouvent avec des
problématiques de demandes d'autonomie
ou alors des problématiques médicales
qui n'ont pas pu être gérée à l'hôpital
par manque de temps et qui se retrouve à
être gérés en ambulatoire avec des
moyens qui sont souvent insuffisants
de façon plus générale
on déplore un manque de communication
entre les hospitaliers les libéraux
c'est très compliqué en ville d'avoir
des avis des hospitaliers et on attend
désespérément un dossier médical en
ligne donc qui nous promet depuis
plusieurs années mais qu'on ne voit
toujours pas
la vision qu'on a aussi sur le système
hospitalier de mâcon sur la dcri mais
c'est le manque de modernisation au
niveau du système informatique il ya un
manque d'homogénéité des des systèmes
mise en place avec des systèmes qui sont
pour parfois obsolètes et d'ailleurs on
voit régulièrement que les hôpitaux sont
victimes de malwares et est
malheureusement avec un système qui ne
permet pas une protection optimale
je vais parler plus spécifiquement de la
santé mentale puisque on voit que
les places en hospitalisation et les
ressources au niveau hospitalier est
également les ressources en cmp sont
largement insuffisantes que ce soit pour
la psychiatrie adultes et
particulièrement pour la pédopsychiatrie
avec des situations qui dépasse le champ
de la médecine générale et des patients
qu'on trouve en souffrance sans de
pouvoir leur apporter de réponse
et pour parler de plus spécifiquement de
l'attractivité de l'hôpital donc ce
qu'on constate lors de lors de notre
passage à l'hôpital et ensuite de
l'extérieur c'est des conditions
financières qui sont
comment dire
qu'ils sont pas pas satisfaisante avec
des échelons bloqué pendant plusieurs
années pour les paramédicaux des
passages au cdi plutôt qu'à la
titularisation avec des avantages qui
sont qui sont inférieures à la
titularisation mes consoeurs et
confrères vont nous parler mais des
internes étudiants qui sont utilisés
comme de la main d'oeuvre bon marché
avec un encadrement lacunaire qu'il ait
des coûts du travail hospitalier
on voit aussi d externalisée une
externalisation des prestations à
l'hôpital donc des recours à
certaines entreprises plutôt que des
embauches salaires donc je pense par
exemple pour pour l'entretien des locaux
mais également des facturations
supplémentaires qui sont réalisés pour
les patients donc que ce soit la chambre
seul mais je parle aussi des coûts de
stationnement qui sont maintenant
facturés aux patients et des
dépassements d'honoraires qui sont plus
en plus pratiquée dans l'hôpital public
et pour finir bien sûr les conditions de
travail à l'hôpital qui sont déplorables
avec une charge de travail importante
que ce soit pour les personnels médicaux
ou paramédicaux des horaires l'on peut
reconnaissance du travail fourni une
impression pour les professionnels de
courir après le temps et ne pas faire du
travail de qualité avec du manque de
matériel des personnels ballotté dans
les services et surtout un manque
d'accompagnement psychologique
particulièrement sur les services qui
ont été concernés actuellement par par
notre part par l'épidémie qui est
toujours en cours et ce qui est vraiment
dommage c'est que ces soignants qui
s'engage l'hôpital public ils le font
avec le goût du service public avec
l'envi du d'aider les autres l'envi du
soin sans questions de rentabilité
on a vu l'espoir pendant pendant la
crise il faut vite
on s'est dit qu'ils avaient peut-être un
espoir avec le quoi qu'il en coûte on
refocalise sur le soin et qu'on arrête
d'avoir une logique de rentabilité
concernant le système de santé il
malheureusement je j'ai peur que qu'on
soit revenu à dessus merci de votre
attention
alors merci merci à vous quatre quand
même de nous avoir exposé en un temps
très ramassé une foultitude de
problématique
voilà je pense les échanges vont être
très très dense et je passe où tu de la
parole à notre un porteur catherine de
roche merci merci beaucoup à tous les 4
de voix synthétisée de façon
bien concise les problématiques que l'on
sentait poindre au d'abord qu'on avait
déjà pour certaines identifié au fil de
nos travaux le parlementaire mais depuis
le début de cette commission denquête
alors je vais parce que on
on sait à la fois centrée sur l'hôpital
parler des internes mais aussi sur ce
qu'est l'exercice en en prend à la
sortie des études si je reviens à
l'hôpital on voit bien qu'il ya un recul
l'attractivité
ce que vous dites sur les histoires de
d'échelon et de gagner assez simple
ubuesque quoi que quelqu'un ça on
l'avait évoqué lors d'une parce qu'on
avait travaillé un peu sur les suites du
ségur avec le ministre vers ans
n'était pas le cas mais les chiffres
sont là les tableaux sont la
caisse qui quel serait selon vous le
savez un peu abordé les mesures
susceptibles parce que bon il ya des
mesures à long terme que l'on va
préconiser mais il ya aussi un besoin
d'avoir des actions qu'ils aient un
effet rapide rapide sur le sur le pétain
et s'il ya des mesures susceptibles de
mobiliser rapidement et durablement un
nouveau vivier de praticiens on pourra
voir les mêmes questions sur les autres
professionnels de santé mais là on va on
va rester sur les médecins ça c'est le
premier point vous avez un peu abordé
aussi les conditions actuelles de
formation lors de l'internât c'est
notamment vrai pour la médecine générale
avec ce cette volonté de s'ouvrir sur
l'extérieur
sur le temps consacré aux tâches
administratives
cette évoqué et souvent nous dit mais
nous on aimerait tous auprès du auprès
du patient faire notre job de deux
soignants et on croule sous des tâches
administratives
qui qui nous plombe une partie de nos
journées quelles sont les pistes
d'amélioration parce que on dit aussi
d'un côté l'hôpital et sur administrés
être administrativement à l'hôpital
c'est un peu un lieu commun de dire ça
en plus plus administratif que d'autres
pays même temps s'il ya des gens me
décharger des soins nom de ta chemise at
il faudra quelqu'un le fasse sauf à
penser qu'on peut rationaliser les
tâches administratives demandées parce
que si c'est enveloppe constante de
notation administrative
si c'est pas soyez un cliché quelqu'un
d'autre le fera on va encore renchérit
administrativement question selon vous
vous lavez un peu abordée à travers les
l'informatisation ça je pense que c'est
une piste de
d'amélioration substantielle de temps
administratif mais aussi à d'autres pays
ce qui permettrait de rééquilibrer votre
votre temps de travail exercice me
soulage un peu abordée et la permanence
des soins en lâchant excuses en
permanence des soins vous l'avez abordé
je vais revenir maintenant sur le volet
installations du territoire parce qu'on
voit bien que si on veut que le
l'hôpital aussi retrouve un peu un
souffle avec dos alors forcément des
humains qui indéniablement à faire mais
il faut aussi que à côté en allemand ou
en aval et puisse y avoir et puisse y
avoir
20 raisin organisation du soin à
l'échelle d'un territoire et à l'échelle
d'une population
qui soient pertinents
qu'est ce qui pousse un médecin à
s'installer sur un territoire
et est ce que la présence de par exemple
décès pts qui ont été un outil comme a
été mis dans la boîte à outils est ce
que c'est quelque chose qui contribue et
quels sont les obstacles vous lever un
peu abordée avec le travail du conjoint
dans les services publics mais qu'est ce
qui pousse qu'est ce que le plus
attractif
pour un jeune médecin qui quittent qui
termine ses études voilà pour un plan
alors je vais vous repassez la parole à
tous les quatre on va pas faire dans
l'ordre inversé vous pouvez répondre à
tout ou partie des questions se posent
et se répondent à toutes les questions
mais le rapporteur a besoin de réponses
à toutes ces questions quand même c'est
normal je voudrais juste ajouter une
remarque moi j'ai été très marquée alors
par tout ce que vous avez dit mais j'ai
entendu quand même la culture du monde
hospitalier encourage les violences et
les agressions parce que si des les
français entendent ça il tombe de leur
chaise parce que pour tout le monde la
culture du monde hospitalier des
soignants c'est la bienveillance et
c'est l'empathie et c'est pas les
violences et les agressions est ce que
c'est la dégradation des conditions ou
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose
structurellement qui encourage ces
violences agressions docteur le chemin
alors à après jouer c'est ce que
l'ensemble de nos collègues vous posera
des questions pour compléter ce que
vient de dire bernard jomier moi j'avais
auditionné un titre comme ça en face à
face les étudiants et notre commission
recevra le 26 26 janvier
l'association des étudiants qui ont
sorti un livre blanc sur un forme de
maltraitance qu'elles subissent et nous
aurons aussi ce matin là nous souhaiter
entendre la conférence des doyens
alors docteur le chevalier
merci je vais commencer par votre
dernière question comment enfin la
culture de la maltraitance à l'hôpital
je pense que quand on
ne peut pas être dans l'empathie quand
on est en souffrance
donc mes collègues que l'on décrit les
études lui montre les les étudiants les
internes en médecine sont en souffrance
je pense qu'on peut lier les
professionnels paramédicaux sont en
souffrance quand on est en souffrance
soi même on ne peut pas être ouvert la
souffrance de l'autre on ne peut pas
vouloir prendre soin de l'autre quand on
est mal traitée dans son travail on n'a
pas envie de bien traiter quand on n'a
pas de temps pour bien s'occuper de
l'autre on est mal traitée comme faisant
un patient par définition c'est une
personne
enfin je dirais pas en france mais qu'il
ya un besoin et qui en situation de
vulnérabilité
quand on est en situation de
vulnérabilité on est beaucoup plus
sensible
à la façon dont on traite ont retraité
au sens slash bien sûr mais je fasse je
parle
je parle pas seulement de
d'un point de vue physique traité
d'enfants du film et comment on est
traité d'un point psy
donc il ya ces éléments donc on ne peut
pas
enfin on ne peut pas attendre d'un
professionnel en souffrance enfin on ne
peut pas s'attendre à ce qu'ils
s'occupent bien d'un patient et ça je
parle de l'hôpital mais c'est pareil
pour l'ambulatoire c'est pareil pour le
médico social c'est pareil pour les
ehpad si on ne règle pas ce problème de
souffrance des soignants peut pas régler
le problème de maltraitance des patients
donc voilà ça c'était pour le côté ans
vaty un futur je reviens sur vos
questions qui se rapportaient plus
pour ce qui est des jeunes médecins
généralistes
qu'est-ce qui est attractive pour un
médecin généraliste pour s'installer
alors en fait je pense qu'il ya
malheureusement il ya eu une erreur dans
la question parce que le problème ce
n'est pas que les jeunes médecins ne
s'installe pas le problème c'est qu'on
n'a pas assez de temps médical à offrir
pour avoir une réponse aux besoins de
santé de la population
donc les médecins vous pouvez essayer de
faire installer le tout les médecins
remplaçants de france parce que c'est
souvent qu'on vise puisque c'est eux qui
sont pas installés vous n'arriverez pas
à résoudre le problème de l'accès au
médecin traitant il ya une augmentation
de la consommation de soins donc on l'a
dit pour les raisons d'augmentation la
population pour la raison de
vieillissement de la population
l'augmentation des maladies chroniques
et donc je lui ai dit aussi pour des
raisons de consommation de sont
inappropriées sur des pathologies
bénignes pour lesquels une ligue
l'éducation à la santé elle pourrait
suffire pour expliquer aux patients que
quand on a le nez qui coule depuis 24
ans pas la peine d'aller voir son
médecin il ya des solutions qui existent
à la maison pour un rhume pour une
gastro-entérite c'est pas besoin de
consulter mais malheureusement il ya
aussi des consultations qui sont faites
à buter administratif enfin avec des
certificats médicaux que ce soit les
arrêts de travail les enfants malades
les certificats médicaux pour la crèche
etc des choses qui prennent du temps et
sur lesquels on demande une expertise
d'un médecin dès qu'il n'est pas
nécessaire là c'est de la paperasse qui
ne sert à rien et malheureusement qu'on
demande aux patients et que les patients
12 et
voilà qui fait perdre du temps à tout
non
ensuite comment éviter comment gagner du
temps administratif
comment faire en sorte que le médecin
fasse de la médecine et moins du monde
des papiers donc là je les dis un petit
peu pour ce qui est des consultations
mais la simplification
de l'entreprise libéral
c'est un des facteurs donc ça a été fait
notamment avec avec les assistants
médicaux mais pas pardon dr chevallier
mais on parle de l'hôpital un tout de
même je sais bien sûr vous pouvez en
parler de l'abaisser deauville mais des
questions là à porter porte sur
l'hôpital
d'accord donc écoutez je pas de problème
juste un point vous demandiez à ce que
laissait ptc attractif alors laissé
fédérer s'est pas directement mais
d'exercice pluriprofessionnelle les
maisons de santé le plus beau fils
younes est attractif et donc comme
madame ring girls a expliqué l'enquète
sur les déterminants à l'installation
montrait aussi que
le fait d'avoir des attaches familiales
sur un territoire le fait d'avoir des
services publics sur un territoire le
fait qu'il d'avoir
fait ses études sur un territoire c'est
des facteurs qui sont attractifs voilà
merci merci beaucoup pour ces éléments
barrichello oui merci je vais faire l'
inverse je le prendre dans le bon sens
vraiment dans le sens que vous aviez
donné pour la réponse aux questions
concernant les mesures immédiates pour
l'hôpital enfin j'ai beaucoup parlé de
qualité de vie j'ai beaucoup parlé enfin
nous avons tous beaucoup parlé de
qualité de vie
je pense que c'est vraiment là dessus
qu'il faut axer parce qu'à l'heure
actuelle ce qui est très important c'est
de effectivement d'attirer les soignants
vers l'hôpital et ça ne pourra pas se
passer si les soignants pense avoir
d'une mauvaise qualité de vie en allant
à l'hôpital public et je pense que c'est
des choses qui sont assez enfin qu'ils
peuvent qui peuvent se résoudre
notamment sur les horaires de travail
sur ses tâches administratives dont je
parlerai également pour prendre un
exemple très bien réelle pour le coup
qui a été vécu et qui est encore vécue
par de nombreux bonds nombreuses
étudiants en médecine
une des tâches majoritaire des externes
consiste à faire des facs donc nous
prenons un bon des facs nous prenons un
bon d'imagerie et nous allons le fax et
pour qu'ils aillent dans le service à
côté ça c'est quelque chose que
l'ensemble des externes ans étudiant en
médecine font mais quand même il ya un
certain nombre d'hôpitaux qui sont
équipés système informatique pour
demander la fin des exams annonceurs le
fax est encore majoritaire et ben de ce
que moi j'en ai connu oblige les gens
et puis jours ça pourrait être
sympathique
bien le feu dont vous faites des facs
quoi les externes fax les externes font
des facs donc effectivement il ya déjà
cette problématique de tâches
administratives qui en fait serait très
simplement résolu résolu pardon par un
parent un outil numérique mais également
en fait c'est externes ils sont censés
apprendre leur métier et donc de
commencer une de commencer nos études
dans un milieu hospitalier dans lequel
notre tâche principale consiste à faire
des facs ne nous donne effectivement pas
forcément envie d'y retourner par la
suite ce que je peux comprendre
également
en dehors de cette petite de cette
petite histoire de deux facs
sûre je reviendrai pas sur les
déterminants à l'installation que
j'avais déjà expliqué tout à l'heure
donc effectivement
l'enquète du conseil de l'ordre montrait
bien que c'était la proximité familiale
donc le fait d'avoir une famille sur
place ça ça aide à l'installation et
surtout les services publics le fait
d'avoir des postes des faits d'avoir des
transports également de les garçons sont
des choses qui attire les médecins dans
les territoires et enfin pour parler de
la maltraitance hospitalière je voulais
juste donner un chiffre qui a été issus
de l'anc et de santé mentale qui
démontrait que 76% des violences qui ont
été déclarés ont été subies à l'hôpital
d'où cette phrase
bien docteur cheikh amar tran
alors pour répondre aux questions de
madame la
rapporteure pour les mesures
susceptibles de juguler là tout de suite
l'hémorragie ou même trouver un retour
de ph vers l'hôpital les faire revenir
il faudrait reprendre en fait leur
ancienneté actuellement il ya beaucoup
de médecins qui aimerait rentrer revenir
à l'hôpital mais leur ancienneté n'est
pas reprise et il serait classé sur des
échelons assez bas et quand tout à
l'heure je vous parlais des
déclassements un des ph il ya même une
petite note alors sur pour cette
nouvelle grille salariale qui stipulait
que les péages qui se délite yonnais
pour repasser le concours ne reprendrait
ne serait pas classés avec enfin serait
resté et resterait sur l'ancienne
héroïne
enfin avec eux leurs anciens des champs
de démission et c'est tout l'ancien
alors c'est vraiment
donc je pense qu'il est je pense que la
correction de la grille salariale
immédiatement pourrait faire ses preuves
pourrait stopper l'hémorragie de même
qu'une permanence des soins revalorisé à
l'hôpital une nuit de garde l épave cher
payé elle n'est pas prise en
considération alors que vraiment
l'hôpital étant le dernier recours on se
retrouve vraiment dans ces situations
catastrophiques la nuit épuisante en
nous même s'il y avait une réelle
surcharge de travail sur certains
secteurs ou
ont pourtant le nombre d'équivalents
temps plein est censé
où tous les postes sont pris mais c'est
qu'il n'y a pas eu de réévaluation de la
nécessité de création postes 1 et il ya
beaucoup d'hôpitaux qui ne veulent pas
créer de nouveaux postes sur certains
services
au niveau des tâches administratives
effectivement on en a beaucoup à
l'hôpital sûr
les choses qui pourraient effectivement
en fait par des secrétaires médicales
malheureusement les secrétaires
médicales il y en a pas beaucoup sur le
marché non plus quand c'est dans tous
les hôpitaux il ya un réel déficit dans
secrétaire et on est amené à prendre
nous mêmes les rendez-vous pour nos
patients lorsqu'on a besoin d'un
avis spécialisés où on a supprimé des
pauses secrétaire médicale ou
en dessous cas je sais que ça ne suit
pas et je ne sais pas si ils ont
supprimé deux façons actuellement il y
en a pas assez sur le marché que ça soit
dans en libéral ou dans le prix dans le
public
sa cession
alors qu'il ya par exemple des pistes
qu'on pourrait
pour pouvoir recruter par exemple les
aides soignantes qui sont en arrêt
maladie un sur des problèmes de
lombalgie qui peuvent pas être reclassés
sur ces postes là on pourrait peut-être
les reformer pour elles ont une culture
médicale qui est là et qui pourrait
faciliter leur intégration
mais il semblerait que c'est plus facile
de les garder en arrêt maladie que de
performer sur des problèmes
administratifs de financement tout
peut-être une piste à explorer un
stimulant
pour attirer peut-être et enlever ce
côté de suradministration
par exemple concours de ph
pour être enfin pour garder nos
chefs de clinique assistant à l'hôpital
on pourrait faciliter le composent bien
jeu puisque tout le dossier est
finalement à l'hôpital ça pourrait être
l'hôpital qui aident à monter ce dossier
pour envoyer au cng alors
qu'actuellement c'est le ph en lui-même
qui a enfin le celui qui veut devenir
péage qui doit monter son dossier et il
ya parfois des ratés notamment pour
récupérer tous les dossiers enfin tour
toutes les preuves de de l'heure
l'engagement sur les différents centres
où il était donc on avait parlé déjà de
la rationalisation du temps par
l'informatisation et effectivement il ya
beaucoup de temps perdu pour récupérer
des examens et parfois effectivement
c'est plus facile de redemander un
examen que d'aller essayer de récupérer
dans un cabinet ou dans un autre hôpital
en
pole et réorganisation régionale de
santé je pense qu'effectivement c'est
une piste con
con pour par exemple si on prend exemple
sur les allemands ils ont des ministres
de la santé like au niveau de chaque
länder et c'est sûrement des pistes à
explorer sur l'optimisation des besoins
de santé pour une région
concernant l'attractivité
donc on avait effectivement chez par
rapport à mes collègues il y à aussi je
pense tout ce qui est facilitant pour
que ça soit même pour les enfin pour les
jeunes médecins pour
les personnels paramédicaux donc on est
en âge de procréer à ce moment là les
facilités de mode de garde des enfants
et ça c'est vraiment important dans mon
hôpital avant il y avait donc beaucoup
de places en crèche les années on a de
moins en moins qui avait même des
centres aérés pour les mercredis ça a
été supprimé ça et je pense que ça ça
peut vraiment enlever une charge mentale
à tous les soignants faisant soi même
les femmes ou les hommes puisque les
changements sociétaux sont là sont
actuellement pour ses modes de garde
pour ce qui concerne la culture de la
violence
même si je pense que mon j'ai peut-être
la chance d'avoir une équipe on reste
empathique on se serre les coudes
effectivement au cours de ma formation
j'ai entendu un des phrases comme la
gentillesse n'a jamais sauvé deux vies
ou encore le fait
on a une culture quand même de la
performance jusqu'au boutiste comme le
rien que le fait de faire des guerres de
24 heures on sait très bien l'origine de
ces guerres de 24 heures c'était
vraiment pour pousser la formation des
médecins pour dans la culture de
performance pour forger leur caractère
historiquement alors que personnellement
au bout de 24 heures les décisions sont
vraiment difficiles à prendre et je
pense pas que ce soit intéressant de le
pousser jusqu'à 24 heures gardons
ce casanova merci docteur
des mesures immédiates et durables
pour sauver l'hôpital
vous imaginez bien et j'en suis bien
désolé que imaginez quand un coup de
baguette on pourrait changer ce qui a
mis 15 ans à être construits ou des
construits suivant comme on voit les
choses dont j'ai aucune réponse à vous
donner immédiate ce serait de la folie
que d'imaginer que ça soit possible en
revanche en revanche je crois quelque
chose moi je crois en l'espérance et au
fil de voir le bout du tunnel ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'aujourd'hui la
perspective démolition de l'hôpital elle
est plus à la destruction à
l'affaissement total qu'à l'amélioration
en tout cas dans la vision des soignants
j'ai l'impression qu'ici personne ne
contredira
et donc
amorcé un mouvement pour essayer de
sortir de cette situation-là ça
donnerait de l'espoir aux soignants et
ça c'est porteur d'engagement
aujourd'hui il n'ya absolument il ya une
lassitude qui infernal parce que toutes
les mesures et je reparle du ségur il ya
eu le ségur il a eu pas ici pour pour
eux excusez moi du mot pour le flinguer
mais il ya je crois de la part des
soignants ressentie très profonde qui
est celui de la de la différence très
importante entre les moyennes
extraordinairement élevé qui ont été
engagées ce qu'ils ne réalisent
incontestable et l'incapacité à la vie à
les visualiser de façon concrète ne veut
pas dire que ça n'a pas été engagé mais
cette dichotomie ce contraste là il est
infernal il est peut-être même plus
décourageant quand le ministre dit avec
le ségur de la santé comme l'avait dit
en comité de suivi ségur on n'aura plus
besoin de réformer l'hôpital pendant dix
ans j'ai eu serment de gorge en me
disant mais comment peut-on dire ça soit
il en est convaincu et je pensais que
ces signes inquiétants soit il n'en est
pas convaincu et je trouve ça aussi
inquiétant qu forme
voilà des propos qui ont une valeur
encore une grande célébrité au ministère
de la santé mais je le crois vraiment
cessé c'est extrêmement important ce
ressenti là vous pouvez demander à tous
les soignants encore une fois y
énormément de bonnes choses qui ont été
faites notamment sur le volet numérique
ce qui me permet de revenir dessus
comment amorcer ce mouvement là et bien
notamment c'est de communiquer ça c'est
quelque chose qui donne envie aux
soignants de rester quand je dis
communiqué s'est évitée je vous avais
donné l'exemple de ce patient qui est
sur le brancard avec la pile de dossiers
et les examens qu'on ne peut pas
récupérer sa porte une charge
extrêmement importante pourquoi parce
que vous allez essayer de retrouver ces
examens l'a donc vous allez appeler des
confrères et consoeurs des hôpitaux pour
récupérer les examens nous imaginez bien
que toutes les étoiles ne sont pas
alignés donc la personne peut être
éventuellement de congés ou partie ou en
consultation donc ce qui pourrait
paraître pour un coup de fil n'est pas
un coup de fil et une dizaine de coups
de fil pour finir par avoir quelqu'un
qui lui aussi a beaucoup travaillé
peut-être va oublier d'envoyer le
document etc la réalité c'est sa
personne n'imagine que c'est un coup de
fil à personne dit ah oui je vous
l'envoie tout de suite jamais ça ne se
passe jamais comme ça donc ça c'est
extrêmement important le deuxième la
deuxième chose c'est trouver sa place et
trouver sa place eh bien ça commence par
séparer définitivement le grade et la
fonction si je voulais vous donner une
mesure immédiate c'est pas que je la
souhaite mais si vous voulez être choqué
bien vous dites on supprime l'école de
rennes des directeurs d'hôpitaux et on
recrute les personnes je peux le dire et
on recrute les personnes non pas sur le
corps mais uniquement sur les
compétences sur le projet sur ces sakhir
au fond le plus important ça ne veut pas
dire de jeu telle omerta sur encore plus
qu'un autre mais c'est à dire on vous
recrutent non pas parce que vous avez
fait tt telle école où l'on vous
recrutent parce que cette école vous a
permis d'acquérir des compétences et
parce que vous avez un projet pour cet
établissement ça me paraît beaucoup plus
simple et pareil pour les médecins pour
les tâches administratives je voulais
dit le numérique le numérique le
numérique parce que et je sais qu'au
sénat comme à l'assemblée nationale la
question de l'accès aux soins et au
débat qui fait parler et même dans les
médias
non évidemment jeune médecin c'est
toujours un peu inquiétant vous savez
pourquoi c'est notamment inquiétant
parce que les propositions qui sont
ralliés je dois le dire toutes celles
que j'ai vu passer au sénat et
l'assemblée nationale sont probablement
inefficace si un rapport de la de
l'adresse qui est sorti là en décembre
qui vient
analyser les mesures qui sont efficaces
ou non pour la lutte contre pour
l'installation dans les zones sous
denses
et ce qu'ils disent et c'est évident on
l'a dit tout à l'heure c'est un des
déterminants à l'installation mais c'est
une huit ans folle c'est de dire ben si
j'ai les proches si j'ai mes proches les
gens que j'aime dans cet endroit là
globalement j'ai beaucoup plus de
facilité à m'y installer et donc me
voilà à une conclusion par rapport à ça
c'est peut-être devrait-on réfléchir à
la mixité sociale dans les études de
médecine qui font partie des études avec
le mou le taux de boursiers le moins
élevé le jour où on aura des étudiants
en médecine plus évidemment qu'il y en a
mais c'est comme les poissons volants
c'est pas la majorité du genre vous avez
des des jeux de médecins qui viennent de
quartiers défavorisés que ce soit urbain
parce que ça aussi c'est des zones sous
denses ou de quartiers de zones rurales
défavorisées mais je peux vous assurer
sa va pas se régler tout de suite mais
je peux vous assurer que le problème va
s'améliorer durablement
et enfin juste sur les violences jeu
c'est peut-être le plus sympa le plus
important pour moi mais en tout cas
celui qui me touche le plus parce que ça
fait un an calice nous on se bat contre
ce problème gravissime mais j'ai envie
de je vais vous donner un élément de
contexte qui vous fait comprendre pas
que les médecins et les soignants seront
plus violent que les autres mais que le
monde médical et l'hôpital en
particulier permet aux violences de pros
de prospérer mais c'est très simple
lorsque vous êtes un terme ou êtes
séquestrés trois quatre ou cinq ans dans
un établissement plus l'établissement
est petit et puis vous êtes sûr de vivre
un amour plus ou moins contrarié avec
vous chef de service et votre chef de
service évidemment il va falloir être
conciliant sage avec parce que sinon
vous pouvez vivre un véritable enfer en
médecine lorsque vous êtes interne vous
ne pouvez pas changer de ville vous êtes
affecté à cet établissement jusqu'à la
fin donc vous êtes totalement à la merci
si vous êtes affecté un livre vous
changer tous les semestres oui vous
changez tout les semaines mais imaginons
vous soyez dans un centre hospitalier de
taille tout à fait modérées vous allez
changer tous les semestres mais vous
allez passer la majorité de vos semestre
dans le cercle dans un service celui de
votre spécialité avec votre chef de
service votre coordonnateur qui est
souvent les deux en même temps qui lui
aura tout le poids sur votre cursus
universitaire et sur votre évolution
hospitalière vous avez raison vous
n'êtes pas à 100 % du temps maintenant
suffisamment significatif pour que ça
puisse être dangereux donc c'est un
contexte qui permet à tout cela de
prospérer et j'aimerais que si vous avez
l'occasion de puisque le rapport a été
publié par la rs nouvelle aquitaine
l'exemple le plus marquant de sa c est l
affaire de poitiers qu'on avait eu à
traiter la sphère de poitiers c'est une
directrice d'hôpital en costa qui a été
mise en examen pour homicide
involontaire à l'hôpital georges
pompidou de paris dans un contexte
d'affaires de harcèlement et moi je me
retrouve avec des internes qui écrivent
je vous donne la substance des
témoignages tous les matins lorsque
j'allais travailler je n'attendais
qu'une chose c'était de me prendre mur
pour pouvoir en finir j'ai vu des
personnes en larmes des années après
alors même qu'elle avait changé de
spécialités quitter la ville ne serait
ce que le fait d'évoquer ce qui s'était
passé là bas et bien aujourd'hui à
l'hôpital de poitiers évidemment
lorsqu'on en a parlé à la directrice qui
a eu ses différences et différents
témoignages les personnes en cause était
le chef de service et le chef de pôle
elle a répondu mais enfin c'est quand
même de bons praticiens vous savez c'est
la bonne vieille formule il faut séparer
l'ombre de l'artiste c'est évidemment
excessivement inquiétant et c'est pour
ça qu'à poitiers tout le monde phare à
la rochelle et que plus personne ne veut
rester à poitiers je viens d'apprendre
même que la seule personne qui voulait
prendre un poste universitaire à
poitiers dans ce service de gynécologie
obstétrique et partie littéralement
partie et enfin la conclusion de ça
c'est quoi alors même que rien été fait
jusqu'à ce que nous mettions le nez
dedans la directrice est toujours en
poste le chef de service le chef de pôle
ont perdu leurs fonctions
administratives mais sont évidemment
toujours en poste et ça c'est la preuve
par a plus b que ce qui vient d'être
indiqué est une réalité une réalité
viscérale et très difficilement vécu
bien
je ferai pas de commentaire je passe la
parole à mes collègues qui vont vous
poser des questions et à nouveau vous
aurez tous
vous allez voir beaucoup de questions on
va commencer avec florence lassarade
merci merci à vous d'être venu exprimer
tout ce tout ce que nous en pressant je
pense que l'histoire du dossier a
numérisé ça me paraît être moi une
priorité mais ce qui ce qui est le plus
prégnant là dans vos témoignages c'est
la maltraitance alors cette maltraitance
elle et
elle est due à des professeurs de chu
puisque vous êtes tous formés en chu
finalement comment est-ce que vous
envisageriez 2
vous l'avez évoqué un certain entêtement
de de pouvoir justement délocaliser
votre formation dans des centres
hospitaliers plus qu modeste et qui vous
permettrait d'avoir une peut-être une
respiration dans votre cursus et où les
médecins et praticiens hospitaliers dont
j'ai fait partie
sentent en appétence de recevoir être
former des étudiants que ce soit des
externes ou même des internes dont
cologne dans les services périphériques
finalement j'étais à langon si vous
connaissez on
souffre vraiment de ne pas avoir de d'un
terme qui aide à au fonctionnement de
services et pour qui les services sont
relativement épanouissant deuxièmement
ce que je voulais savoir c'est quel est
le poids de deux parce que j'ai compris
quand même qu'il y avait pour certains
les patients sont avides d'informations
de
il arrive beaucoup plus informés plus ou
moins bien d'ailleurs mais ils ont
besoin d'un temps passe auprès d'eux
plus important qu'avant apparemment il
ya il ya une demande accentuée
dsk la maltraitance peut aussi venir de
l'usagé
est ce que c'est enfin est-ce que ça ça
arrive forcément et j'avais une
troisième question
que j'ai oublié se passe pas grave je
pense que vous aurez des tas de des tas
de questions
merci france laurence cohen
oui merci pour vos propos liminaire je
trouve qui corrobore toutes les
rencontres qu'on a déjà pu avoir dans le
cadre de la commission denquête et puis
effectivement
sur sur le terrain moi je vais avoir
disons de deux pôles de questions
effectivement autour autour de l'hôpital
il me semble que le problème que vous
avez souligné c'est le problème de la
gouvernance beaucoup enfin une grosse
une grosse partie et il me semble que la
problématique c'est quand même de
redonner du pouvoir aux personnels d'une
manière générale aux
aux usagers et de faire en sorte que
les directeurs fin les gestionnaires
puissent être en accompagnement est pas
en direction
comme c'est aujourd'hui où finalement
ils ont ils sont là pour pour réduire
les
dépenses et donc avoir quand même une
certaine toute puissance sur les choix
les choix qui sont faits au niveau du
budget de l'établissement les choix qui
sont faits au niveau du haut niveau
aussi du projet donc c'est redonner du
pouvoir avec un conseil d'administration
qui effectivement intervient sur
notamment le budget le projet de
l'établissement etc qu'est-ce que qu'est
ce que vous en pensez il me semble que
la maltraitance pour une part elle est
effectivement vous avez parlé d'une
certaine culture mais elle est aussi
liée pour moi à la gouvernance et puis à
la toute puissance d'un certain nombre
de
l'hôpital manque par exemple
il s'est basé sur la tarification à
l'activité pour beaucoup on va il ya une
perte une hémorragie de personnel donc
poitiers c'est quand même clair on va
préférer garder
des ddv des professionnels qui aurait dû
être de mon point de vue ça n'engage que
moi renvoyé mais parce qu'il faut garder
les compétences et parce que voilà donc
c'est je trouve que là c'est lié aussi à
la gouvernance qu'est-ce que vous qu'est
ce que vous en pensez et
troisième élément toujours autour de ces
questions là c'est sur le tutorat c'est
à dire que en fait je quelqu'un d'entre
vous l'a souligné à partir du moment où
les conditions de travail sont
énormément dégradé où il manque des
personnels où tout le monde court dans
tous les sens que ce soit les médecins
que ce soit les infirmiers et
infirmières
il ya plus cet accompagnement qui était
quand même une lettre de noblesse de
l'hôpital où tout pas à l'ailé sun qui
choisissait d'aller travailler à
l'hôpital disait bon on a peut-être un
salaire moindre mais au moins on a cette
qualité tutorat etc d'accompagnement
aujourd'hui ça n'existe plus donc
modifier les conditions de travail et un
aspect qui pourrait redresser la barre
et dans le même ordre d'idée j'aimerais
avoir un peu plus d'éléments sur ce que
vous allez vous avez souligné
concernant les ph 1 en disant qu'il y
avait eu en fait très trop grasse
rétrogradation je vais y arriver parce
que on avait eu l'occasion c'était en
mai 2020 sur ma proposition catherine de
roche avait organisé une audition du
docteur emmanuel durand qui est du
syndicat national des médecins
hospitaliers qui avait déjà dénoncé on a
déjà posé cette question à hominis vers
ans qui a pas voulu
répondre donc avoir peut-être un peu
plus d'éléments sur les revendications
et la façon dont elles sont accueillies
et la toute dernière chose c'est vous
avez parlé du lien avec l'ambulatoire là
aussi l'ambulatoire ça fonctionne à
partir du moment où c'est très encadré
c'est à dire où il ya des personnels en
en nombre suffisant notamment
paramédicaux or ya aussi une pénurie
para médicaux très très très très forte
et est ce que vous pensez que
le l'attractivité pour les jeunes
médecins vous n'en ai pas parlé peut
aussi passer par la création dans tous
les territoires de centres de santé qui
correspondrait donc à une à ce que ce
que parce que beaucoup de jeunes
médecins portent c'est à dire des
réductions du temps de travail je pense
aux horaires un travail salarié et un
travail d'équipé et le lien entre
centres de santé et hôpital parce que
pour moi ça travailler la main dans la
main s'est pas coupé
merci je précise juste à mes collègues
et puis à vous-même aussi que nous
allons arrêter cette séance
impérativement à 17h40 voilà que chacun
ait une idée du temps nadia saut
merci donc je serais assez concise merci
beaucoup docteur parce que vous avez
assisté sur un point qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur à savoir ceux
des chiffres que j'arrive pas à
récupérer si on sait qu'il ya 90 % des
gamins qui font leurs études mais aussi
une cuisine de la ville faut pas
s'étonner qu'il irait s'installer après
dans la ruralité et je n'arrive pas à
savoir est ce qu on pourrait avoir la
typologie peut-être vous vous les avez
la psychologie des étudiants qui font
médecine parce que auquel cas il faut
qu'on fasse des passerelles pour que les
jeunes des territoires ruraux et accès
aux études de médecine parce que sinon
on servirait
ben oui mais c'est la deuxième année
et voilà donc après jeu sera plus rapide
vous aurez pas me répondre parce que je
voudrais vous livrer un témoignage j'ai
toujours l'impression de bien faire
quand on est dans l'hémicycle qu'on vote
des exonérations fiscales des seuils de
machins et je me suis rendu compte
lorsque j'ai rencontré mathilde rencker
à arleuf à arleux dans le morvan où vous
avez fait un congrès d'un terne en
médecine cet hiver peut-être étiez-vous
présent également et on a échangé et je
me suis rendu compte je vous ai
complètement fausse route parce que
c'est vraiment le coeur c'est
l'attractivité c'est leur donner envie
et moi j'étais vraiment une des plus
motivés pour voter cet amendement qui
devait vous obliger à venir faire une
année supplémentaire dans les
territoires ruraux jeu taper du pied
parce qu'il n'est pas encore le décret
d'application et mathilde me dit mais si
vous nous obliger à venir dans des
stages dont vous n'avez pas vérifié ni
la qualité ni les conditions
d'encadrement nigré comme on le frappe
d'abord si on est forcé on va partir en
courant et
organiser les choses mieux et on viendra
avec plaisir et voilà je tenais a livré
ce témoignage parce qu'il faut
constamment qu'on soit en lien avec vous
sinon on fait fausse route
merci alors en visio nous avons jean sol
oui monsieur le président madame le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs chers
collègues bonjour j'ai deux protections
avons posé la première concerne tout
particulièrement le mal-être vous avise
évoquée
est ce que vous pensez qu'ils aient
plutôt corrélé à vos conditions de
travail c'est à dire l'exercice exercice
professionnel sont corrélées à la
représentation que vous aviez de votre
message quand vous êtes rentré dans
l'autre dans votre cursus d'études de
médecine est ce que vous avez trouvé
donc à la région puisque vous trouvez à
l'arrivée dans le nez dans nos
établissements de santé d'ailleurs
qu'ils soient publics ou privés ou en
cabinet ça c'est ma première question
avez-vous donc on regarde de
l'expression de de ce mal être et de ses
25% une de leurs collègues vous avez
évoqués étant dans une situation
psychologique
pas brillante est-ce que vous avez au
sein des institutions dans lesquelles
ils travaillaient des espaces d'écouté
de dialogue at il de partage qui vous
permettra peut être de démembrer c'est
la question suivante tous à la charge
administrative que vous avez vous pu
évoquer les hommes et les autres est ce
que vous voyez nous rappeler en quelques
mots en quoi consiste-t-elle je vous
remercie
merci jean et dernière collègues à poser
des questions sonia de la pauvre provôté
pardon
vous provoque
sonia paulo borges bafouille mais mal
venu voilà oui mais merci beaucoup
bon moi je suis très triste on entend de
tout ça parce que j'ai un souvenir
absolument formidable et en ballon et
joue à marie qui fait la même tête de
mes études de médecine et j'ai fait du
périphérique à l'époque ont été pris en
charge on apprenait plein de choses en
dehors du chu est vraiment voilà il ya
une ambiance formidable et on était
respectée et c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'on
n'était pas très payer mais on était
récompensé par la formation est ce qu'on
vous transmettait et donc ma première
question c'est vraiment est ce que ça a
changé à ce point quoi je suis
incroyablement
comment dire
de cette situation oui temps en temps on
était un peu
martyrisé mais on était nombreux à se
défendre enfin je ne sais pas ce genre
n'avait j'ai le sentiment que la
situation s'est terriblement dégradée
parce que tout ce que vous signalez ça
existait mais pas dans les mêmes
proportions et on arrivait à lutter
contre quoi relais donc c'est vraiment
ce sentiment là et
voilà donc je voudrais vraiment si vous
aviez quelque chose à dire c'est qu'est
ce qu'est ce qu'est le cloud est près de
nous dans la façon dont les choses ont
changé est ce qu'il ya une maille manque
de convivialité entre les étudiants où
on avait des moments de soupape qu'on
avait tout ça et est ce que cette
dimension là est une dimension qui a
complètement disparu ça c'est quand même
des études fantastique et des métiers
absolument formidable voilà ma deuxième
question force force sur l'art sur
administrations les protocoles les des
surveillances
le fait que effectivement je veux
témoigner il ya des postes c'est que
secrétariat qui ont disparu
et il ya même des postes de secrétariat
qui ont disparu au profit de plates
formes de prise de rendez vous par
exemple la paix hpc s'est passé et
effectivement on à renforcer
l'administration bureau à l'hôpital et
on a diminué d'administration de terrain
donc je pense qu'il faut quand même se
poser la question de cette
administration de terrain qui était
utile et qui partis qui participent et
du collectif de soins dans les services
via que le sécrétariat les soignants
fonctionner ensemble
et peut-être que c'est sa dimension là
finalement de la proximité
l'organisation de proximité dans
l'hôpital je sais pas quel est votre
point de vue qui parient nécessaire de
remettre en place de renforts renforcer
ou de re réfléchir et puis il ya de
réflexion l'exercice mixte ville hôpital
ça se pratiquait beaucoup et on échange
beaucoup avec la ville quand on était à
l'hôpital les médecins venaient faire
des vacations ça a été
proposée dans
les cités au départ est-ce que vous avez
le sentiment que ça sera l'élément très
moteur pour permettre l'installation
donc à la fois aux villes et à la fois à
l'hôpital dans les hôpitaux généraux
moins dotées ou dans des secteurs et des
territoires où il ya une forme de
désertification médicale et est ce que
pour vous c'est une mesure majeure à
mettre en place et à renforcer c'est ce
qu'elle était supprimée en premier dans
les hôpitaux pour
pour des raisons gestionnaire et
budgétaire un cd premier truc qui ont
été supprimées et de deuxième sujet que
vous avez évoquées et sur lequel
compterait après avoir trahi vous avez
évoqué de le fait de se spécialiser dans
d autres exercices médicaux la pédiatrie
a été évoquée la gynécologie c'était
tout ce qui relevait des cévennes avant
que toute façon des
rsg chose qu'une partie des ce qu'ont
connu cette époque à la disparition
laisse tevez est clairement on arrive à
la fin des crs en ville là tout le monde
pas en cardio andrew stalbow en gynéco
en pédiatrie est donc sacré une carence
supplémentaire de spécialistes qui
n'étaient pas des os mais qui faisait
une grosse partie du job
la prise en charge ambulatoire et ceux
là même qui avaient également
d'évaluation hospitalière et qui crée le
lien entre la bible hôpital donc est ce
que vous pensez qu'il faut vraiment
favorisé cette spécialisation
des exercices médicaux de façon à
favoriser les liens avec hôpital fort
merci
bien je vais vous redonner à nouveau à
toutes et tous la parole quelques
minutes pour répondre aux questions de
nos collègues et puis pour voilà pour ma
mot de conclusion
ce casanova alors rapidement cette fois
ci mais il y avait deux gros sujet c'est
le premier c'est celui de la
maltraitance il y a
un élément pour le pour le régler et
fait j la maltraitance en général et
qu'en aidant maltraitance en fait je
mets aussi l'absence de formation comme
il est toujours la formation médicale
c'est un caprice détruire c'est la
possibilité de prendre en charge des
patients la meilleure façon qui soit
pour les années à venir donc c'est
excessivement important est une des
possibilités pour pouvoir aller voir
ailleurs comment on allait voir dans les
hôpitaux périphériques mais il ya deux
commissions c'est un peu technique mais
à une première commission que saper la
commission d'agrément nouveau qui permet
d'accueillir des internes dans un
établissement dans le service et puis
une kessel de la répartition des postes
qui peut dire qu'on a un peu on peut
avoir le sésame pour pouvoir accueillir
mais rien dit content qu'on accueillera
bon là il ya des avancées comme majeurs
qui ont été réalisés au niveau du
ministère de la santé à notre demande
puisque même si le règlement le prévoit
y est il n'y avait strictement aucune
visibilité sur ces commissions les
personnes n'étaient souvent pas tout
convoqué il n'y avait pas de procès
verbal pas de signature je vous laisse
imaginer que le maître mot dans beaucoup
de ces commissions c'était le copinage
et le copinage globalement il a tendance
à revenir vers le chu donc ça c'est en
train de se régler je l'espère en tout
cas y ait des engagements qui ont été
pris par le ministre et là je le salue
comme je ne suis pas revanchard pour
tout ça va changer les ça va changer les
choses je le crois en tout cas il ya
cette volonté pour la question de la
gouvernance même peut-être faut-il se
poser la question de la décentralisation
de la nominer s2 les dénominations et du
rôle des élus au niveau local je crois
que on en un système de santé
excessivement centralisé
est ce que c'est une bonne chose je
crois qu'on est de moins en moins de
personnes à le penser donc peut-être
faut-il revoir aussi le le poids des
élus locaux et des acteurs de terrain
quand je dis d'élus locaux dont je parle
des élus mais parlant et dans quelle
nomination des directeurs d'hôpitaux
excusez-moi
des directeurs d'hôpitaux je pense qu'il
faut redonner aux territoires l'amène
sur
leurs hôpitaux quand on voit
l'importance que cela peut avoir en
termes d'aménagement du territoire en
termes économiques etc il me semblerait
logique que les territoires puissent se
ressaisir de ce problème
vous aviez parlé de moyens qui veut de
maisons de santé c'avait été évoqué oui
le centre de santé à nous on commençait
à évoquer on y travaillait avec notre
réseau de médecine générale ou qu aux
questions des pépinières dentaire mobile
ça comme ça l'idée elle est relativement
simple c'est d'avoir des grands axes de
communication mais des zones qui sont
pas forcément bien doté et ce qui est
certain c'est que partir tout seul dans
un endroit qu'on connaît pas ça fait ça
donne pas toujours en vie il ya des
grands solitaires mais pas toujours en
revanche le fait de se dire on va
pouvoir se former dans une maison qui
serait mise à disposition on va se
former avec des maîtres de stage mais où
on va y aller à 3 4 5 pendant six mois
là évidemment il ya prolong une
attractivité beaucoup plus important
c'est ce genre de perspective qu'il faut
développer et puisqu'on disait encore
une fois que le fait de connaître un
territoire ça c'est un facteur
d'installation mais peut-être que c'est
ce genre enfin c'est pas peut-être c'est
ce genre de deux
d'actions qui vont pouvoir avoir un
effet et le tout dernier point qui était
sur la dernière question c'était sûr
est-ce que ça tant changé que ça oui ça
tant changé que ça le monde hospitalier
a énormément changé et c'est un vrai
problème qu'on a avec les plus anciennes
générations aujourd'hui on arrive plus
je vois la réalité actuelle
avec le filtre de leur vision d'abord
jardinons le monde a littéralement
changé pack l'hôpital d'ailleurs et
aujourd'hui on a un système vous parliez
des dés de l'hyper spécialisation et des
diplômes et des ddos belle époque vous
commenciez faire une spécialité puis
finalement vous allez faire de la
dermato etc il y avait une vraie
flexibilité aujourd'hui vous commencez
vous passez le concours puis après vous
allez devoir vendre chèrement notre peau
puisque vous allez préparer une
spécialité et une fois que vous l'avez
c'est terminé vous allez pas changer de
spécialité sauf des conditions
excessivement difficile et donc
aujourd'hui vous avez de plus en plus de
spécialités de plus en plus étriqué de
plus en plus enfermer et on va vous dire
que vous avez intérêt à bien bosser
parce que c'est ce qui va déterminer la
suite de votre vie et ça ça donne quoi
ça donne des personnes dur des prix mais
souvent peu solidaires et évidemment
lorsque vous n'êtes pas de solidarité
lorsque vous avez une telle dureté
lorsque vous avez des situations qu'on
voit catastrophique de corpeau monde
comme on le dit dans les prépas de
personnes qui cache des bouquins et sait
comment voulez vous quand vous avez une
personne comme ça un de vos collègues ou
une de vos collègues dans un service qui
pleurent comment voulez vous avoir la
moindre 11 d'empathie donc beaucoup de
personnes qui partent avec de bonnes
intentions mais une telle machine qui
pendant cinq ans vous broie et bien ça
donne des personnes avec des valeurs
humaines parfois très discutable
merci docteur chamard août
alors par rapport au sentiment de
dégradation des conditions de travail
actuelles fait cette situation elle
allait déjà mal avant le coc vide et je
pense qu'elle devient de plus en plus
insupportable depuis le collège et je
voudrais vous rappeler quand même
quelques phrases du président le 25 mars
2001 lorsqu'il est venu à mulhouse en
situation catastrophique à mulhouse pour
rappeler on avait dû monter un hôpital
militaire sur un parking il avait dit
beaucoup a été fait sans doute pas
suffisamment vite pas suffisamment fort
l'engagement que je prends ce soir pour
eux et pour la nation toute entière
c'est qu'à l'issue de cette crise un
plan massif
d'investissements et de revalorisation
de l'ensemble des carrières sera
construit pour notre hôpital
c'est ce que nous leur devons c'est ce
que nous devons à la nation cette
réponse sera profonde et dans la durée
voilà pourquoi ça devient de plus en
plus insupportable
concernant la mort là on me demandait
des détails sur les charges
administratives qu'on peut avoir
effectivement en plus des tâches
inhérentes aux médecins par exemple
lorsque j'ai besoin d'un nouveau un
nouvel appareil de monitorage
hémodynamique inde en service de
réanimation
je vais on va donc avoir plusieurs
industriels qui vont nous contacter 1 et
qu'ils ont présenté les différents
appareillages on va choisir mais il va
falloir monter un dossier qui va passer
dans une commission donc et on n'a
jamais la réponse
sur notre demande de financement sur cet
appareillage et au bout d'un moment nous
dit bah non de toute façon au niveau
financier
on ne reverra que le matériel nécessaire
on a pas d'investissement supplémentaire
à faire donc on a perdu du temps à faire
un dossier qui prend du temps quand même
il faut justifier notre demande pourquoi
on veut c'est un fait ce
cet appareillage qu'est-ce que ça va
changer dans notre pratique et
finalement on se servent à rien et donc
c'est des charges comme ça un peu
administratives qui ne servent à rien et
qui nous empêche de faire notre travail
correctement après effectivement on a
tout ce qui est
décharge de responsabilité au train
comme disait mais mes concerts par
rapport aux certificats des certificats
complètement stupide pour dire qu'un
enfant non pas pour moi mais aucun
enfant a droit d'aller à la danse des
choses comme ça ou encore tout ce qui
est certificat d'assurance ans que nous
parfois on a effectivement en
réanimation pour tout ce qui est
accidenté
tout à l'heure on parle également du
lien ville hôpital qui était nécessaire
et effectivement le statut
de ph
le statut unique de ph qui prévoyait en
fait un pourcentage de l'exercice à de
définir en fait pour chaque praticien
important c'est important un pourcentage
pardon d'exercice à l'hôpital et à la
ville pourrait effectivement favoriser
un exercice mixte qui s'est perdu
effectivement à la suppression des
postes de praticiens attachés a
effectivement ce sont les premiers
postes qui ont été supprimés non
renouvelés pour des raisons budgétaires
et c'est cette dichotomie ville hôpital
serait plus elle en fait une activité
seulement privé dans à l'hôpital public
qui engendre des dépassements
d'honoraires et le fait de vraiment
senti arisée l'hôpital public et faire
son activité privée ailleurs serait
beaucoup plus sains notamment au niveau
des relations entre personnes également
on avait déjà évoqué avant le virage
ambulatoire un qui est nécessaire pour
désengorger l'hôpital et ça c'est
vraiment au prix d'une formation
augmenté de médecins généralistes je
pense avec des ratios à 50 50 au minimum
qui serait nécessaire pour pouvoir
réinvestir la ville et le fait de
peut-être réinstaurer les crs
effectivement pourrait réajuster
notamment les besoins en pédiatrie en
gynécologie médicale pour pour les
besoins de du public
vous me demandiez par rapport à la
grille de péage chose qu'il en était
donc actuellement jeunes médecins à
déposer un recours au conseil d'état
nous n'avons pas de nouvelles pour
l'instant et donc les 8000 ph également
qui ont fait le recours auprès de leur
tribunal admistratif n'ont pas de
nouvelles sur sur leur déclassement mon
nom est là pour l'instant
merci beaucoup à vous la rigueur
oui
alors je vais reprendre un petit peu les
questions sur le numérique effectivement
c'est une évidence que c'est un métier à
développer au plus tôt il n'y a pas de
ya pas de questions là dessus je pense
qu'on est on est quand même plus tous
d'accord sur la question en ce qui
concerne les maltraitances je voulais
revenir sur quelques quelques petits
points on sait qu'on a quand même 60 %
des violences qui en général sont
commises par des supérieurs ce qui
entraîne et comme on l'avait comme ça a
déjà été dit et répété une omerta qui
est extrêmement importante à l'hôpital
puisque on a peur de perdre un poste on
a peur d'être invalidée de stage on n'a
pas envie d'en parler parce qu'en plus
part de parler de dire d'une situation
qu'on a vécu difficilement ou de subir
des violences c'est une situation de
faiblesse et on veut pas paraître faible
devant l'école allait donc il ya
vraiment une situation d' omerta
l'hôpital qui qui est impressionnante et
qui il faut absolument lever il faut que
en fait cette impunité des agresseurs
elles n'existent plus parce que c'est
cette impunité d exode des agresseurs
qui empêche les personnes les victimes
de parler comme vous voulez vous parler
si vous savez que dans tous les cas ça
ne changera rien on a souvent ce type de
discours de d'étudiants d'un terne ou
d'externes qui nous rapporte ce genre de
choses
j'ai pas de chiffres sur la distinction
entre les chu et les ch je suis pas tout
à fait persuadé qu'il n'y en ait en
l'occurrence des internes de médecine
générale on est très souvent dans les
haies dans les centres hospitaliers de
périphérie c'est quelque chose qui est
très très courant pour les internes de
médecine générale puisque les chu
craignent plutôt des internes d'autres
spécialités basques en cardiologie c'est
mieux d'avoir un interne de cardio et
c'est donc nous on est très souvent dans
l'est dans les centres hospitaliers de
périphérie ces violences elle subit
enfin elles surviennent également en
revanche c'est vrai que d'étendre la
possibilité de faire des stages dans les
centres hospitaliers de périphérie ça
pousse ça fait justement une autre
pratique de la médecine et ça nous
permet de découvrir un autre un autre
monde un petit peu puisque le centre
hospitalier de périphérie n'ont pas
forcément les mêmes moyens que les chu
donc ça nous permet aussi découvrir une
autre pratique de la médecine est
d'avoir un lien entre la ville et
l'hôpital qui est pas du tout le même
que dans les chu parce que justement les
sages de périph on fait pas tout à fait
la même chose donc si ces développements
de stages hospitaliers et ça va être une
nécessité notamment pour les et enfin
pour les externes pour les étudiants en
médecine avec l'augmentation du numerus
clausus ils vont bien être obligés
d'aller dans d'autres centres
hospitaliers que le chu donc c'est
développement des stages en milieu en
milieu ambulatoire également notamment
la fin la périphérie et le milieu
ambulatoire nous on est en milieu
ambulatoire en médecine générale on a on
a cette chance d'avoir des stages en
milieu ambulatoire
je parlais notamment de les ouvrir à
d'autres maîtres de stage par exemple de
faire en sorte que les médecins les
internes de médecine générale ayant
stage auprès de sage-femme ou auprès de
pédiatres de gynécologues ce qui n'est
pas le cas à l'heure actuelle nous avons
des stages en pédiatrie nous avons des
stages en gynécologie mais ces stages
sont en immense majorité encore fait
dans des centres hospitaliers
alors qu'il pourrait être très
intéressant d'ouvrir notre pratique et
de le faire en milieu ambulatoire
puisque final c'est plus l'exercice qui
va qui va nous convenir par la suite
donc pourquoi pas
c'est une demande que nous on porte
d'ouvrir ces stages en ambulatoire sur
l'exercice l'exercice partage et je
pense que ça a été assez dit et répété
effectivement c'est un c'est quelque
chose qui peut permettre de créer un
lien assez fort et ça permettrait
justement de de faire en sorte que
7,7 ce maillage territorial en fait ce
fait se fasse également entre la ville
et l'hôpital
petit juste petit pardon
petit détail enfin petit détail n'en
sont pas vraiment détails le petit souci
par rapport aux stages en périphérie
c'est surtout justemment notamment par
rapport aux étudiants qui n'auront pas
forcément les moyens d'y aller et encore
une fois il faut bien évidemment
développer ces stages mais les
développer dans des moyens qui fait avec
des conditions qui soit adéquate avec
des hébergements qui soit disponible
avec des moyens de transport qui sont
disponibles quand on est étudiant que
quand on est interne les internes
déménageant enfin on peut être amené à
déménager tous les six mois ça peut être
compliqué ça peut être très compliqué de
trouver un logement en deux semaines des
fois on a ce nom on a nos affectations
de stage trois semaines avant et en
l'absence d'hébergement territoriaux en
absence d'un terne fin de ce qu'on
appelle les anciens d'internât ruraux ça
peut être très compliqué de trouver à se
loger dans ces territoires ce qui
justifie aussi le fait que les gens
restent plus souvent dans la ville dans
laquelle il habite initialement et ses
problématiques sont les mêmes en fait
qu'on retrouve par rapport aux
formations initiales puisque en fait les
formations initiales sont faites dans
les grosses villes dans lesquelles il ya
les centres hospitaliers et pour exemple
en dans la région auvergne rhône-alpes
il ya quatre facultés de médecine dans
la région centre val de loire il y en a
une
les deux régions sera à peu près de la
même taille je comprends pense même que
la région centre val de loire est plus
grande ça dénote aussi une de ces
problématiques
et ensuite je
voulais juste revenir sur les centres de
santé effectivement les centres de santé
c'est une pratique qui peut être
intéressante pour pour les pour les
jeunes médecins pour les jeunes
installés çà peut être ça peut être une
une solution adéquate cependant
les centres de santé il faut qu'il soit
construit avec les professionnels parce
qu'on a souvent ce type de problème
aussi ou une collectivité territoriale
une collectivité locale va construire un
bâtiment en disant je construis le
centre de santé comme ça des médecins
reviendrons et bien en fait non puisque
si ces centres de santé ne sont pas
adaptés si les locaux sont pas adaptés
ci a pas de pharmacie à côté s'il n'y a
pas de laboratoire de biologie à côté si
l'hôpital de proximité le plus proche il
a 70 km c'est quand même compliqué
d'implanter un centre de santé dans ce
territoire donc les centres de santé le
développement bien sûr mais toujours en
collaboration avec les professionnels
qui vont s'installer puisque c'est eux
qui le seront le mieux à même de
déterminer leurs besoins
et puis c'était tout et ben merci
docteur le chevalier vous c'est vous qui
allez conclure
très bien merci je vais être consiste
bien puisqu'il ya assez peu de questions
qui concernent les jeunes médecins
généralistes
je vais revenir sur la question de
compter ensemble ambulatoire
c'est-à-dire l'attractivité des jeunes
médecins est ce que vous passez par la
création de centres de santé alors je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec madame
renckert sur sa réponse sur la
construction elle est dans la
philosophie des centres de santé soit
fait avec les médecins mais je peux dire
de façon générale que oui en effet le
salariat peut être attractif pour les
jeunes professionnels et que ce soit
salariat ensemble de santé ou
dans les structures hospitalières
quand on part au libéral mais je reviens
encore une fois vous le disiez le
problème c'est qu'il faut qu'ils aient
dû personne et personne en nombre
suffisant là on revient toujours sur la
problématique du nombre de médecins et
j'avoue que j'aimerais bien aussi avoir
on va pas pouvoir là mais avoir en fait
votre regard de sénateurs sueur sur
cette problématique pour ce qui concerne
les médecins généralistes en fait
qu'est-ce que vous pensez que font les
jeunes médecins généralistes à la fin de
leurs études ce qu'ont fait les jeunes
médecins généralistes travaillent ils
histoire ils s'installent soit il
remplace mais c'est une minorité mais il
travaille donc en fait on peut obliger à
s'installer où on veut mais en fait
ils travaillent déjà ils ont ils
contribuent au système de santé donc
je j'aimerais bien avoir votre vision
parce qu'on a sûrement un
constat qui est différent parce que moi
je vous avoue que je j'ai du mal à
comprendre certaines propositions sont
faites
[Musique]